so I go to my spot and my car's not
there my car got stolen I wonder how
easy it is to stay at Ikea it's got to
be pretty easy for all these kids are
doing it how long did it take them 230
to 237 seven minutes so I took longer to
adjust the seat what do you think is
gonna happen to my car I think it'll be
used in a smash and grab or something no
they use it for a crime and they did and
they just ditch it yeah or they'll just
keep on using that car to steal a better
car and just trade up and then the
dude's just in Ferrari by the end he's
like man I missed that KIA just a TLC
show called trading up up theft would it
be stripped do you think tires seats
you're not gonna get much money for
parts for a Kia cues are a fine
Automotive Nick some people need Kia
parts I mean you need every part right
now
oh nice dude you want these two to get
the death penalty I think so yes hey
edit yes edit yes do you want these two
to get the death penalty
yeah hopefully they find it man I think
they're gonna find it